it's been a month since we got our hands
on the galaxy buds plus and we've been
testing them comparing them to
comparable ear buds and using them in
the real world here's what we think
about them in who we think should buy
the galaxy buds plus over the other
options out there now before we begin
there were a few things that we're
lacking with the original Galaxy buds
like for example active noise
cancellation poor microphone quality and
latency and we'll get into those things
in just a minute even before we got our
hands on the buds plus we were surprised
that Samsung priced them at $150 only
$20 higher than the original buds
however the old buds are now available
on sale for around $100 or less so we'll
let you guys know if it makes sense to
pay the extra cash for the buds plus
later on in the video the very first
time we tested and heard the buds plus
using the dynamic sound mode we were
blown away by the sound quality and
volume they sounded incredibly good with
very bright highs and there's a really
good reason for it
the bus Plus actually feature two
separate speaker drivers a tweeter for
high frequencies and a woofer for mids
and bass on a lot of other ear buds like
even the air Potts Pro there is only one
driver that has to take care of every
frequency which is quite difficult
compared to having multiple drivers for
this reason the buds plus sound great an
inner sound quality comparison our
conclusion was that they actually sound
a little bit better than the air pods
Pro which we honestly didn't expect
since they're $100 cheaper now of course
that's not the only reason to buy
wireless earbuds so let's get into what
was a bit disappointing the buds plus
now have two microphones instead of one
so we expected better mic quality but
when we compared it to the original buds
we didn't hear much of a difference just
listen to it yourself compared to the
air Potts Pro as well this is a
microphone quality test during a phone
call using the original Galaxy buds this
is a microphone quality test during a
phone call using the new Galaxy buds
Plus this is a microphone quality during
a call with at the airport's pro this a
microphone quality during a call with
the Galaxy buds plus in putting these
tests aside we use them in the real
world through
actual phone calls and we were told that
the quality of the mics on the buds plus
is way behind the ear pods Pro and if
you really think about it
the ear pods have a stem that puts the
mic closer to your mouth
unlike the buds that barely stick out of
your ears so it makes sense why the my
quality would be worse however I really
like that the buds Plus have such a
low-profile design lacking any kind of
stem that sticks out this means you can
change your shirt sweatshirt or even put
on a motorcycle helmet without having to
take your buds out of course using the
ambient mode to make sure you can still
hear your surroundings now getting into
that ambient mode it honestly doesn't
work as well as the transparency mode on
the earpods Pro which makes voices sound
a lot more natural and not tinny like on
the bus plus one missing feature on
these buds is active noise cancellation
but they're obviously much cheaper than
earbuds that pack that feature so I'm
not taking off very many points for that
on the plus side they seal in your ears
pretty well so they do a really good job
of naturally blocking noise but if you
travel a lot on airplanes you should
definitely consider getting earbuds with
active noise cancellation but I think
not a lot of people are flying for a bit
seeing what's going on in the world
right now now there are some benefits of
not having that feature like not having
to pack extra noise cancellation
hardware inside of the buds that take
space away from the batteries now these
buds plus actually pack 85 milliamp hour
batteries compared to 58 on the original
bus which is a huge difference in this
along with improvements in efficiency
gives the buds plus ear buds 11 hours of
battery life compared to only 6 on the
originals this is honestly excellent
blowing away a lot of other ear buds
like the air pods Pro in terms of
battery life in the real world this
makes such a massive difference if you
use them at work it's really nice not to
have to recharge them compared to having
the pop the air Potts Pro back and the
charging case before the end of the work
day and if you include the extra battery
in the case you get 22 hours of total
battery life not only that but charging
speed has improved as well compared to
the originals we also tested out the
buzz plus with an
iPhone 11 Promax and we were surprised
to see that the experience was actually
pretty good
so we recommended people who can't
afford the air Potts Pro to simply go
with the buds plus a big reason for that
is that Samsung just released a new
Galaxy buds Plus app on iOS which gives
you a lot more customized ability and
fine-tuning of sound now one of the
things we tested between the air Potts
pro and the buds plus was latency and we
saw that the air pods were much quicker
in terms of lag time between tapping the
screen and hearing sound for that the
buzz plus have a gaming mode which
reduces latency and while it did help a
lot and we recommend Android users to
use that feature while gaming the air
Potts pro we're still a bit better in
terms of latency we actually made a
video where we compared the buds plus to
the air Potts Pro and the sony WF 1000
XM threes we concluded that Android
users who don't want to spend at least
two hundred and twenty eight dollars on
the Sony's should just go with the bus
plus despite the lack of active noise
cancellation now with all of that said
we've been extremely impressed with the
Galaxy buds Plus and mainly for three
reasons the excellent battery life the
dual speaker drivers and the $150 price
tag gives you such a good balance of
features and with that even though you
can get the original Galaxy buds for
around $100 on sale we would honestly
recommend everyone considering those
buds to just pay the extra cash for the
Galaxy buds plus because they're
honestly that much better if you enjoyed
this video tap like and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one and make sure to check out one
of those two videos right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]